desafio do bolo a realidade Ok começamos
com uma batata este obviamente que é
bolo Ah quem é que eles querem enganar
Claro que sim bolo Red Velvet adoro
carne Duvido que seja bolo duvido é bolo
Como assim bolo com osso Uh tá muito bem
feito este outra batata este clá que é
realidade pois pois uma laranja eia bem
isto passou calma uma coluna Isto é real
é é bolo ai com chocolate branco ainda
por cima olha outra vez outro bolo ia
bem É o mesmo vídeo ok um tomate bolo
Claro que sim dá para ver a longe Claro
mais mais e isto é um avocada avocada é
um abacate é bolo bolo bolo de certeza
isso mostra mostra ele não
mostrou não é realidade
Este bolo uma Pepsi Este é é verdadeiro